Leena this started this short story give
us the origin and path the adaptation
for this project um well I was at a
party Hollywood Reporter party
celebrating my love she was on 3535 and
chillin James Frey walks up to me he
says he's an idea for a movie that he
can't write he's like - black man black
woman on the first date on the way home
get pulled over by a police officer
things escalate they kill him I
self-defense get in the car and go I was
like you're right you can't write that I
can and so I said and he said like had
outlined in title I said I don't want
the outline I want the title I was neat
that seed and obviously like you know
I'm a fair person I want to give credit
where credit is due so I was like yo
we'll share like story by credit but
like I want to take that and like go
write a script he was like have at it
so and that's really where the journey
began for me where i sat with that and
started just doing you know character
work started beating things out my road
maps were Martin Luther King and Malcolm
X
she was Malcolm he was Martin by the end
of the movie they would have swap places
and and really don't also want to break
Convention obviously yesterday Louise's
a really cool movie and somewhat of an
inspiration but I didn't want a harvey
keitel in this movie and i didn't want
the sympathetic cop that has to you know
you know he looks at the criminal who he
has to bring to justice or whatever i
was like nah i don't want that i wanted
to stay with these characters and i also
didn't want to reveal their names to the
end when they died because I wouldn't
know Trayvon Martin's name of a
vigilante and killed him I wouldn't know
Mike Brown's name was know Eric garner
his name Sandra Bland's name and so on
and so on so that was the things that
you don't know our names until someone
kills us but also it was the thing I was
playing with in terms of what as a
writer I just hated writing names into
dialogue anyway because I was like you
don't usually do that so that's really
weird up again I just kind of like
started writing than just boring all my
[ __ ] onto my laptop and then queenís
knows what came out of that what drew
drew this this this feature and the
first features before most also
producers here Lena and everybody so I'd
been for years
I
I'm also a Molina's manager for years on
a hunt for millionaires first movie he
was a very tough task
he got sent all kinds of script from
every corner of Hollywood there were a
lot of ideas out there what everyone had
an expectation of what Molina's first
movie would be and no one really
understood what we were looking for was
something contemporary something
grounded something real something that
was speaking to the day that we're
living in the times that we're living in
and you know she was getting we were
getting sense you know another period
slave story another you know or a
musical biopic or dance you know step up
9 it's just all kind you know and and
people thought because Malina came from
music videos that you know music music
music in Mullane was always very
specific about you know there are our
musical stories that that Molina wants
to tell but they are few and far between
and you know we were looking for
something that was contemporary grounded
artful but also you know could speak to
the masses so I remember there had never
been a script that I'd read where I
thought this is from Elena it just
hadn't happened and the day I remember
that I read Queen and slam I knew within
the first you know 15 pages this is the
one and Pam when'd you come on board and
this is the first film for your your
partnership with Brad Weston make ready
it's a road trip film but also a team
that went on the road he tell us a bit
about your joining and about the journey
that you all took with the film yes um
so after this wonderful team was all
together and they were ready to go out
and find partners and a home to make
their film and financed their film Brad
and I had the privilege of sitting down
with everyone and we were so deeply
passionate I mean this film is it's one
of those you know it's one of those
things as a producer and a financier
that you dream about is finding bold
audacious just in-your-face stories with
singular vision and Lina and Molina are
that they have a singular vision they
have a powerful voice they are two of
the most extraordinary women I've ever
had the privilege of working with and I
think for Brad and I starting our new
company
this is everything you know for us it's
all about giving people support and
allowing people to have their vision and
to create their vision without feeling
like they can't speak their truth and
that is really what Brad and I believe
in as patrons of the arts as producers
as something you know just our whole
career we've brought him have been
together a really long time in very
different iterations of our lives
both at big studios in a small studio at
New Regency you know where he did the
revenant and Birdman in 12 years of
slave but you know for us make ready was
a chance for us to be brave and for us
to be on our own and for us to give the
opportunity to a new voice a new
generation and just really be supporters
of the arts and this film Queen and slim
is a hundred percent that and everything
we believe in standing in stand for
Molina first feature yes it's a film but
it's also a photo essay a journal a
tribute piece how do you approach this
Lina comes you with the project how do
you how do you take it on you know I
approach every project I do kind of like
a thesis you know I'm very much a
student and I believe in educating
yourself about craft and history and
time and place and character I knew I
wanted it to be authentic and all my
directing choices came from what was
real because I needed that honesty I
needed that to resonate with people and
I needed to honor and she you know paid
tribute to those who had lost their last
sub police brutality and that's really
where I started you know I wanted to
carve this journey I think of it
somewhat as a reverse slave escape
narrative you know they're traveling
south instead of north
and there's a real connection I think
you can see the history of our black
people really weave through every frame
and every word and dialogue and it was a
meditation on blackness and so I started
with our culture you know and I really
wanted to show the diversity of who we
are as a people our voices and and how
we take space how we inhabit the world
and how we live in this country I knew I
wanted to start in somewhere that was
cold that felt like they were
disconnected and in terms of their
relationship and as their relationship
warmed up we would travel south and feel
the richness of the landscape kind of
inform their connection I had a
connection to Cleveland because of I
have been there I shot there before and
I thought it really resonated because it
was the last stop on the Underground
Railroad before slaves would get to
Canada and I thought historically it
metaphorically had this this real
parallel is also where Tamir rice was
killed and they'd still have the death
penalty so but Lina have written that
into the script it was honest it was
true and so I pushed to start there and
then we we went to New Orleans I love
that city and I thought it has a
diversity of us in a showcases that and
so we moved to New Orleans and we shot
primarily in and around New Orleans and
then we make it to wish I Mississippi is
supposed to be Florida but I really
wanted to create this like very
authentic black Odyssey and and base all
my choices in that in Daniel so when did
you come to the project when'd you get
the script in the sort of this order of
of magic coming together and and and
what grabbed you I
I set down with lino very early on and I
she sent me the first draft she just
finished it and um and it was just like
I was a fan I'd loved her pile of the
Shire and I was just a fan of her work
and for she's really special and she
sent me the script
and then it usually takes me four hours
to read a script just an hour
pasted on a pace to a piece of paper and
I was at war what is going on here
and it kind of was a similar feeling how
I felt if when I refer straight girl it
was the kind of so unapologetic so kind
of like can you make this and also why
didn't anyone think of this before like
it's kind of like they had that element
about it seems so obvious yes and so I
kind of hit up Lina and I've never done
this and I still haven't ever done this
time I've ever done in my life and I
said I won't play Slim and I was just
like and then she's like wait hold on
Molina has to has to read it and I kind
of had cool a way out and I sat down
with Molina we had a we supposed to have
a coffee and then we kind of just just
connected but for me it was the world
it's all about um things feeling organic
john saying i think if if the one for to
work together is it's a two-way street a
different you shows up John saying so if
I thought that these incredible women
weren't really feeling me I wouldn't I
wouldn't want to intrude because I just
want it to be the best version of this
film Jose Annan and they were the ones
that were steering that ship and I want
to feel supportive imagine how different
did this spill just about everybody how
different did it feel on set what kind
of environment that you all create to
make this this this a different
experience and not just a different film
I mean I think there we go I felt
instinctively different from me was
because we had complete autonomy we are
we refused to give the the project so
any studio that wouldn't give us final
cut and universal you know and Donna
Langley and everyone agreed that that
was what was necessary for this film to
to really hit hit hit you in the in your
soul and be an experience and so that
was the biggest thing and I think we
just really hadn't we I felt empowered I
think to like do whatever we do even
with the marketing stuff so that was
what was so unique about it was it was
like the first time we were like oh
we're in charge like for real
yeah I believe you know Lena and I both
know our worth we know the value of our
culture and our stories we know how
they've been mistranslated and
appropriated and we're really protective
of that and we wanted to give you
this story from an unfiltered lens
without the white gaze and teaming up
would make ready who are very supportive
and empowering to creators to speak
their truth like Pam said that was
really important that we had that
control of our narrative and and that's
even in the marketing of this film you
know it speaks to us and speaks to our
culture we have collaborated with so
many different black artists you know it
feels like a community comes together to
support even felt like that we had our
premiere the other day and all these
amazing you know it was family it was
only time 2 Chainz and Natalie Portman
saying you know we honor Beyonce so I
think that that space and that freedom
to create something that's completely
unfiltered and you had the control of as
a as a filmmaker is what felt different
for us and also that it was me and Lena
at the helm like this amazing sisterhood
this partnership that we were supported
by everybody our amazing cast and crew
and they really allowed us to steer that
ship and and that takes immense trust
you know that you don't find really
anywhere I think in this industry yeah
and it wasn't our native tongue that was
the thing because we've been watching
movie I watch movies man movies are a
part is they are woven into the fabric
of our lives
they tell us who we are and we know who
white people are because that really has
been like you know and I'm a person who
is such a student of it like I have like
if you look at my arm it's all Wizard of
Oz that isn't my movie Bible like Judy
Garland was right here you know
Scarecrow to me like that's my Bible
that's my motto
it's like whatever we looking for it's
already in our backyard we don't need it
that is there so I've learned the
language I know that language very well
All About Eve like you know saying all
these like Casablanca I know the
language but there's a language that we
speak as well we have a language as well
we also have a broken English and that's
what I wanted to be on the screen and so
I'm really honored to be in this
building because I hope that we can also
honor our language as well
our narrative - it's important that we
be here as well because we also are
woven into the fabric of America
you know Academy Queen aslim thank you
thank you